thank you
[Music]
so a 29 year old man went in to take the
written portion of his driver's test
they didn't let him take it why not
because they didn't think he looked like
his picture ID so they were like how do
we know it's you aren't they the ones
that administer the Fisher idea I know
right well he has an actual
identification card
so it's not his driver's license it's
his ID card but basically they wouldn't
let him take his driver's license
because he didn't look like his ID was
it a fake ID no his real ID oh he just
didn't look like the picture of it oh oh
we got burnt what is that are those burn
scars yeah well I mean who's the [ __ ]
idiot that couldn't tie the two together
and be like well duh it was a real idiot
so he goes he tries to tell the guy
look man like I went through a horrible
disfigurement I'm a burn victim and the
guy was like well why didn't you take a
new photo why didn't you take a photo
while you're burning huh and he says he
says I don't I didn't think I was ready
yet to be photographed like this yeah my
whole identity is flipped upside down
you crazy [ __ ] not my problem
which DMV is this the [ __ ] Pico
Rivera one it's not Las Vegas because I
went to the DMV out there they're
[ __ ] cool man it's not it's 90
000 Pizza
so this guy went through a horrible
accident where he was collecting scrap
metal at like an abandoned Factory
and he thought because it was abandoned
they were going to tear it down soon he
didn't think any of the wiring was live
and then he grabbed the copper bar sent
11 000 volts to his body turned him into
a human Fireball oh my God oh God and uh
yeah this guy was luckily lucky to be
alive he basically died momentarily and
then was uh then came back to life in a
way holy [ __ ] only to go to the British
DMV yeah and here to say you don't look
nothing like a picture I know it's it's
super sad and here's his uh photo before
so that was him
yeah well I mean it also looks like he's
he's in I was like oh [ __ ] he does look
different yeah really I actually thought
he looks like the facial structure like
the eyebrows and the cheeks it looks
kind of similar it looks like from a
different time I think most people can't
tell the hair the crazy thing is that uh
there's a there's many crazy things
first thing is the conversation between
him and that guy it's [ __ ] heinous
but also he's been there twice before to
take the test he didn't pass the other
two times that's why he's there for the
third time but the first two times he
didn't get any problems the person who's
administering it was like okay cool this
third time is when finally some guy came
out with just a huge [ __ ] Lightning
Run up his ass and just was telling him
he can't do it
um but yeah that's what uh the guy was
saying the conversation sucks let me
tell you a little bit about what they
were saying he said so when he's trying
to reason with a guy he's like yeah I
wasn't ready to change my ID yet I'm
still coming to terms with my new
appearance and it's pretty awkward for
me and then um
he said like uh he also wears a hat all
the time to hide his like his basically
is like exposed like
and it just so it's so crazy right and
they're telling him like take his hat
off and he's like I sleep with the sun
like I don't take it off and they just
keep and he's asking him like why are
you being so hard on me and everything
and the guy's just like it's not my
problem you won't be doing your test
then whoa it just had no sympathy and he
said uh what was the point like did they
think that after he takes off his hat
they're gonna be like oh okay yeah you
weren't [ __ ] around I see but it's
like because he has his hat on he's like
you know what
you know you're you're being difficult
this is not you even some people can be
drunk with power that work at the DMV
dude that is like to a level I've never
I didn't even know existed I mean what
did they think this guy was hiding who
his true identity was because there's if
you're really concerned about that
there's other ways to figure it out do
you have other forms of ID yeah you know
like or like was this guy in the news
well he even showed him uh does this guy
look like a bird victim he showed him
other photos of himself not like
pre-accident and post-acts he was just
trying to show as much as he could and
the guy was like not my problem my
problem yeah just a total [ __ ] ass
see this is why
Karen's are sometimes awesome because
when you have a Karen on your side and
they're [ __ ] throwing it down at the
[ __ ] whatever you're at customer
service [ __ ] you're at Target Walmart
whatever they're there to the rescue and
then they start solving not only their
own problems but everybody's problems in
the line okay that's actually that's a
good take that happened to me at a
Starbucks I was at a Starbucks at
downtown and then I forgot what happened
but the lines started getting longer and
longer and there's maybe like 12 people
in the line and then uh the the Karen in
front of me she was like can you believe
this [ __ ] can you believe this [ __ ] and
then for me I'm just I'm just gonna wait
for whatever's to clear up right
she goes to the front whatever the [ __ ]
she says uncl unclog the Starbucks
toilet and all of a sudden everyone just
starts going forward
she [ __ ] saved the day really what
did she do I don't even remember did she
do the manager thing or that didn't even
need to get there
no she even asked Amanda I think she
just went up there and she cleared up
whatever the [ __ ] was happening maybe
she said there's a huge line you need to
start another register right now enough
but it just started going it just
started going really fast I'm like damn
she saved the day man that's awesome
that's why I um I hate like doing this
um going like City stuff because you
can't complain to anyone yeah yeah like
that's the person you're supposed to
come they have too much power I am the
governor I know and I'm like right yeah
it's like look I just need I just need
one thing I just need to change my
address that's all he goes fill this
paper out this paper out three forms of
ID and then go back to the [ __ ] end
of the line it's like come on man I just
need to change the address man what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah but when you're in Las
Vegas though man they're nice
the workers there so different from La
bro how did they do that how did they
achieve a nice DMV
yeah dude I went in and then they're
like oh this one's wrong dude you got to
go back you know I'm gonna save you some
time just fill out this form and then
we'll just get this knocked out today
just oh you don't have to wait in line
come back and see me afterwards I'm like
what and you know what's crazy
um that the Vegas DMV is actually more
overpopulated than the ones here because
of everyone moving there so they're
actually slammed so before I thought the
overpopulation thing and like the
underserved thing was like a legit
excuse but when you go to the DMVs there
and people are like camping out since
midnight to get in at seven or whatever
you're like wait this is way more over
packed but like yeah like Joe said I
went to uh at my I just helped my dad
get like his plates and stuff and then
when I was there the lady saw like my uh
driver's license she's like you're a
veteran she was like I'm a veteran too
she's like you know that you if you go
it's just you wrote down this address
like all this extra stuff that people
don't usually usually they only answer
what you ask for right she wrote down
all these things she got if you go here
to like whatever assessor's office she
goes you get this done you never have to
pay registration in the state of Nevada
ever again for being a veteran yeah and
that's like what like 400 500 bucks
every year wow dude and then I was like
oh okay and then she was just it was
just so nice like she was telling me all
these extra things that usually they
they don't like they're not trying to
make your life better it's just whatever
you want they do it you know but then it
was like I'm not trying to make your
life worse here in Southern California
when you go to DMV dude yeah like did
you sign this form nope all right make
another appointment one month from now
and come back yeah that's exactly I
literally just went to DMV I think like
two weeks ago because my driver's
license expired because this is my
birthday right happy birthday thank you
I go there but uh when I got that
license that wasn't expired I was living
living at a different address La style
I've actually been to three different
addresses since my license expired so
when I go there I'm like hey I try to
renew my uh driver's license online but
it didn't let me change my address so
I'm here to change that but I uh but it
did let me uh pay for registering a new
driver's license and instead it mailed
it and I was like wait a minute you
don't let me change my address but you
mailed it to the wrong address tried to
go to the DMV and I was like hey I think
you mailed to the wrong address but I
need to change my address and I need a
new license they're like well it's
processing it hasn't been sent yet it's
going to go to your new address because
it's processing I can't do anything you
got to come back in one month
when it's already processed and then
from there you can change your address
and then we'll find you a new one oh so
here's a piece of paper for the next two
months to drive and imagine like you
have a regular job right like a nine to
five and you already had to take that
day off and who knows how long you had
to wait to take that day off and the
boss finally approves you okay cool uh
next Thursday and then when you go they
go this Thursday doesn't work you kind
of wasted a whole [ __ ] Thursday you
got to come back another Thursday
this can all move digitally like
completely why do we still have paper
why are we yeah why are we doing this I
think it's what you know like the term
kafka-esque have you heard that term
which one Kafka s it's a term that we're
uh basically it means that a certain
thing exists only for the purpose of it
existing so it is there's a lot of
redundancy in government it's operating
a specific way just to do it that way
like there's no other reason doesn't
help anything it's only keeping itself
alive so if you find a reason that you
know it should be obsolete you're like
hey we could do it this way it's gonna
go no we're gonna keep it like this
because if we do that then all these
people lose their jobs and we don't want
to lose our job right well AI is coming
so you sign up for a crypto account
you're straight up like on your computer
at home [ __ ] scan your face right ID
passport verification like all that
stuff I'm like dude you can do from your
home now yeah I could do online banking
and that's pretty online banking is
pretty secured yeah it's like online
banking I was like how do you do that
but like if they're okay with it why
can't the DMV be okay with it I think
it's like you know when you have like a
bad manager and the manager is always
trying to make up reasons why they're a
good manager but they're still a bad
manager and they just keep going I saved
you from this I handled it before you
even saw there was a problem and it's
like oh that's great it also looks like
nothing happened yeah you know it's it's
that type of [ __ ] we're like it's
something you just need to be people to
digitally process that information
that's coming through on the other end
so it's not like you're completely but a
lot of this information a lot of the
information never needs to be looked at
until there's some reason to do to look
at it like if it just exists as data it
could just algorithm right right or even
one one huge change like let's say okay
you gotta keep it the cave FS whatever
right I think Eve a one dope change
would even just be the change in
Attitude dude yeah so instead of like
going me DMV can you help me with this
and she's like
hmm you know like
because you've been going to like Triple
A in the DMV it's way too it's so
different but but I will say though
imagine if all of us had to work at the
DMV for just one week would we be
[ __ ] over Humanity I mean it sucks
because it's like the customer
experience is pissed everyone's pissed
by the time they see you right so every
single person you see is [ __ ] mean so
you want to be being back to them and
you won't lose your job because it's not
a for-profit company so efficiency isn't
what they're there to do they just dare
to [ __ ] do the same task over and
over and over and over I think that's
where like jobs like this
um it doesn't encourage a more efficient
better system there's no incentive yeah
no there's no incentive you don't get
paid more to do it
the all the way up the chain you don't
get more money for processing it's
exactly what I feel like happened
between taxis and Ubers is back when
like the taxi people were uh protesting
and saying no [ __ ] no no over and over
taxi taxes and it's like you thought
back to all the times that taxis had no
repercussion for screwing you over for
talking to you like [ __ ] for treating
you badly for refusing to take you
somewhere there's no or for [ __ ]
driving anywhere because that you
couldn't follow it on your map yourself
there's no penalty whatsoever and it it
would piss you off and you walk into a
taxi there's like vomit and smells like
[ __ ] and then you can't even leave a bad
review you can't do anything about it so
that's where you're like you know what
not the better numbers are cool
Innovation yeah and other countries are
all digital like why can't we like our
systems so I think it's the same thing
because let's say they started
implementing a new system what's your
[ __ ] Elon Musk made it and goes hey
there it is he made a DMV click go and
it's ready to go and then DMVs all
started like protesting would you have
empathy for for that nope because you
were me because you're based on a
personal experience of like dude I
remember being [ __ ] on at the DMV so
no I'm not going to support this [ __ ]
but I will support the Las Vegas DMV
because they're announcing they honestly
they are yeah and and they have a cafe
but not slot machines
I'm so surprised they don't have slot
machines
[Music]